[Music] I ca
n't help but want to close this precious lie. I want to pull this precious lie out. I can't help it. I'm so excited, I'm so excited. You have a
genius face. I want you to pay close attention
to me. You're so beautiful, I want to show you my hair.  It's a
push, it seems complicated. This emotional love
is cute. After all, it's an exquisite decoration. I
just want to keep it. The expression on your face
is a reward. Thank you very
much. I knew you would take care of me. Even if I
say so much, it's still not enough.  I
love you so much that I can't help but express my feelings.
Joy, gratitude, perfect happiness. I
want you to pounce on me. Even if it's only for a minute or a second, you're asking me if I want you, but I
have to show you that you're completely different.
No matter what the situation is.  I
want to face you
[Music]
from
DET